44 jours seulement après avoir mis les
pieds au 10 darning Street lister à la
pression et l'annonce quelques fonctions
affirmant qu'elle n'arrivait pas à
mettre en œuvre ce qu'elle avait promis
peu après son arrivée au pouvoir le
ministre des finances présenté un plan
qui comportait entre autres des baisses
d'impôt pour les mieux nantis
il faut une nouvelle approche a-t-il
déclarée mais rapidement la valeur de la
livre sterling a chuté la Banque
d'Angleterre s'est inquiétée pour la
stabilité financière du pays après
seulement 37 jours en poste le ministre
des Finances a été poussé à la démission
nommée son successeur a annoncé un
virage à 180°c
ne faisaient que dépenser ça a été
difficile d'évaluer cela pendant la
période covid évidemment mais la liste
russe et la preuve par 9 en fait ils ne
savent plus gérer l'économie et ça je
pense que c'est le dernier clou dans le
cercueil
et puis pour les problèmes
puis il y a eu une série d'épisodes
chaotiques à la Chambre des communes
d'expliquer que les Strauss absente de
la chambre lors d'un débat d'urgence ne
se cache pas sous un bureau
de confiance mercredi soir au cours
duquel des dizaines de députés
conservateurs n'ont pas appuyé leur
propre gouvernement prise dans la
confusion les strose elle-même s'est
abstenu
à 17 élus conservateurs d'arrière bain
ne cachant pas son exaspération
il y a quelques jours à peine s'affirmer
qu'il n'était pas du genre à abandonner
mais les appels à la démission étaient
de plus en plus nombreux ce tableau IDE
avait même mis en ligne une vidéo
comparant la durée de vie politique de
la première ministre à celle d'une
laitue
[Musique]
pour l'opposition travailler ce qui mène
par quelques dizaines de points dans les
sondages les conservateurs ne peuvent
pas décider entre du sort du pays il
faut une élection générale
maintenant Raphaël on se demande quelle
sera la suite en tout cas il y aura une
course à la direction et ça va être
expéditif on n'a jamais vu ça
parce qu'on doit connaître Céline les
résultats d'ici vendredi prochain les
membres seront appelés à se prononcer
nous dit-on ainsi que les députés qui
joueront un grand rôle il y a des
candidats qui semblent déjà intéressés
parmi les noms qui circulent Wi-Fi
sunnaque celui qui a perdu la course à
la direction contre l'histoire en
septembre ainsi que Boris Johnson
l'ancien Premier ministre qui a quitté
ses fonctions en septembre et qui
seraient selon plusieurs médias
britanniques intéressés à présenter sa
candidature vous entendez dans le
reportage le chef travailliste Céline
dire qu'il souhaitait une élection
générale pour que la population puisse
se présenter mais on voit bien que la
direction qui a choisi de partie
conservateur c'est plutôt donc une
course pour se choisir un nouveau chef
et si il y a pas de mouvement du côté du
gouvernement bah la prochaine élection
elle est prévue que pour 2024 voir le
début de 2025 donc en attendant ce qu'on
verra bien c'est un cinquième chef
cinquième Premier ministre à entrer à
Dandin Street depuis que le Parti
conservateur est au pouvoir il y a 12
ans le passage pouvoir été aussi court
que chaotique merci beaucoup Raphaël
merci au revoir